[Applause]
close the hole open we get set nine man
box and Jacob's love burger we all love
brent musburger roll tide obviously you
know Josh Jacobs coming from Alabama and
what a season he's had I called him
yesterday on this show before the game
my Offensive Rookie of the Year
candidate right now clubhouse leader
there and noble put the board up here
from our Los Angeles broadcasting Center
crew last night Cleland Ferrell max
Crosby three combined sacks two and a
half from the kid fairly clearly his
best game as a pro Hunter Renfro three
catches three of his four catches
resulted in a first down this kid Alec
Ingold from Wisconsin undrafted rookie
free agent his first career touchdown
and again Jacobs is fourth in the NFL in
rushing that is part of the rookie class
that was drafted by my ba my guy mike
Mayock and I do believe before we get to
Mike my Delta four we have exclusive
Rich Eisen shows out of him of him
celebrating last night's victory correct
mas a ter achieve with the W by the
unforgettable name the man to call it
better go well show the general manager
of the Oakland Raiders he is mike Mayock
how are you Mike awesome rich we really
had to go there
[Music]
[Laughter]
man you know what these are good these
look yes we do have to go there quite
frankly we did how does this obviously
look you know marathon not sprint you
know anything can happen it's a crazy
crazy League that said as you feel right
now five and four after that last night
that we in the black hole where
everybody's going crazy in Oakland your
feelings are what right now Mike on the
positive side rich I think we've got a
group of kids that compete and that's
the most important thing to me as we're
trying to build a foundation but were
five and four well we're not a win out a
great football team by any stretch we've
got a long way to go and I think the
important thing is we got it and I
learned this years and years ago it's
everyday if you get a little bit better
just every single day a tiny bit better
and keep that your focus it's a powerful
force multiplier over a season and
that's what I hope I'm not worried about
playoffs I'm not worried about records
I'm worried about this young team
keeping their focus and just trying to
get a tiny bit better every single day
that kid Jacobs is special Mike you when
did you first see how special he could
be well I told this story often but real
quickly I mean when I took the job it
was plus or minus January 1st last year
and the national championship game was
in San Francisco right down the road
from Oakland so I went to the game and I
had watched a bunch of his tape and
loved them but remember I'm like five
days on the job here which goes cruising
and I came back from the game and back
to the office that night and I put
together a seven play cut up of Josh
Jacobs and if you're gonna play running
back for Jon Gruden first you gotta pass
Patek
then you got to catch the ball and
finally we can talk about you as a
running back and I put a seven play reel
together where was him knock and
defensive ends on there but three times
in pass bro
him catching two passes and then finally
two runs and at 5:30 the next morning or
whatever I walked into John's office and
said I want you to watch a guy we're
going to take him in the first round
test and he's like Mike again it's
January there's no way and I like coach
just watch seven plays with me and we
watched the seven plays and all of a
sudden he was like 10 he he's pretty
good Mike he's not bad and and so to say
he was on our radar early would be fair
and we tracked him all the way through
the process I gotta tell you Mike when
you mentioned Pass Pro and obviously
catching and running and just the way
that he does pass protect and the way
that he can smoothly catch out of the
backfield and the way that he caught so
quickly and the violence with which he
runs and the way that he runs and
carries people after contact I'm
watching him and I'm thinking who does
he remind me of he reminds me of
somebody and I'll tell you he reminds me
of Zeke he looks like Zeke Elliott to me
and I'm wondering how far off you think
I am well and I mean to you to
paraphrase Bill Parcells
from 30 years ago yes let's not go and
anoint him or anything you know he's
nine games into his career and we're
cautiously optimistic and you know
what's cool rich is he doesn't look like
he's 224 pounds but he is mm-hmm and his
lateral quickness is outstanding he'd
you know he didn't run a great 40 and I
was at the Alabama throw day praying he
would run slow I mean I was literally at
the finish line time and I'm hoping it
would be bad because I knew that would
turn some people off so I think his
lateral quickness his ability to make
people miss his pass protection his hand
and the cool thing is he's you know it
looks like it the play is blocked for
one yard and he gets four and then it
looks like you block it for four and he
gets ten so if this kid takes care of
all the details he's got a chance to be
pretty good you know it's been a while
since I was on a broadcast with you Mike
where I gave my opinion in terms of an
evaluation and held my breath to see if
you agreed with me or not it's been a
while I felt like I'd I felt like it's
been 2006 through 2018 all over again
right there well I gotta be up I feel
like I spent most of those twelve or
fourteen years watching you play with
your phone under the table no I am i was
actually when I was doing that I was
paying attention to something called
Twitter that you always poo pooed Mike
you know check my last tweet it was
probably before I took the job maybe so
maybe so art Brockman's on that mike
Mayock here on the Rich Eisen show best
game out of ferrell as well and that was
you know interesting how back when it
was 2006 to 2018 and if you had gone on
and I found that works out like this
feral kid and then somebody didn't draft
him in the top five they'd say what's
wrong with my general manager and then
you actually were a general manager and
did it and we're somewhat criticized for
the pic what do you think of his
development Mike I think he is who we
thought he was and he's not flashy he's
gonna be a really good NFL player I
don't think we helped him at times I
mean we asked him to play a bunch inside
and that's hard he's never played inside
in his life so he kind of took one for
the team from us because we asked him do
some things you had never done before
the last two games the last two games
he's been outside only I thought the
second half of the Detroit game a week
ago he started to come on against a
pretty good tackle and then last night
he flashed some of what I think we hope
to see morals and he stout against the
run and he's a power rusher that's got
just enough slips to be a good pass pass
rusher also so I'm happy people got to
see a little bit of what we think he can
be a few minutes here with mike Mayock
raiders general manager here on the Rich
Eisen show what have you learned about
being a GM all through your first
several months on the job that you
didn't know or you thought you needed to
learn going in Mike
it's it's 24/7 12 months a year you're
on call every minute of every day
there's really never downtime where you
just kind of get this take a step back
and go wow you know I want to go put my
feet miss and and drink a beer because
there's always something going on but
it's also for me rich what it was all
about was three-and-a-half hours every
Sunday for Thursday night whatever
that's what it's all about and it was
what 30 I texted my six younger brothers
and sisters in the locker room before we
in right before the kick week one
against Denver I texted my six brothers
and sisters and said wow it's been 35
years between NFL games for me and I
can't believe how I'm feeling right now
well I mean the previous times the
previous times you played how do you
handle the not being able to control
what's going on in the field how do you
handle that um I try to be stoic up in
my box but I'm not it's a it's a it's an
emotional roller coaster and it's it's
been everything I had hoped and more
rich bets so how much hard knocks did
you leave on the cutting room floor mike
Mayock I sensed it was you with a pair
of scissors
this past summer just just slicing it up
and leaving it on the cutting room floor
with a chain saw not scissors how much
what do you do there I don't think they
love me films Mike you go way back with
everybody in that building come on now
yeah I may have ruptured her
relationship or two I'm not sure when
you know I'm a I'm a rookie GM I don't
know what I'm doing I haven't hard knock
there was hard and you know I always
trying to protect my head coach I was
trying to protect our team and I thought
that was my job so and were you hiding
Jacobs from that too cuz we didn't see
him at all I mean he wasn't on that
summer at all Mike
one of the reasons I love this kid is he
came to me on the first day of training
camp and he said you know hard knocks
asked me to do this and somebody else
asked me to do that and he said do I
have to
I said no gosh you don't and as a matter
of fact if you don't want to do it tell
me right now and we'll take care of that
and he said I just want to focus on
football I don't want any other
distractions and now in hindsight how
good does that look about the maturity
of this 21 year old man his story is
amazing
I mean his story is absolutely amazing
and Waller did you where did where did
he fit into all this
Mike and what what he's become and
obviously you've signed him long term
now his story now I'm glad that that got
through the hard knock hard knocks
goalie that blew me away just see I had
no idea about his journey and how he's
wound up a crucial member of your
offense not just for this year but from
Vegas and years to come Mike I thought
the the Hard Knocks crew the NFL Films
people did a great job detailing that
and I went to Darren to make sure it was
okay with him hmm
and to show you his maturity and where
he is in his sobriety he said Mike I
want to tell my story and I want to help
people to the extent I can now with my
platform and he's an is an extremely
mature intelligent and serious young man
who wants to help other people and I
think we get so fired up about wins and
losses in the NFL and the penalties and
the officiating on and we kind of forget
about some of these special young men
and he's one of them rich he wants to
give back I'm so excited for this kid
both personally and professionally I
can't tell you and then just a couple
more guys I want to hit with you Derek
Carr Mike obviously you mentioned it's
what it takes to be a running back in
Gruden's system I can only imagine what
it takes to be a quarterback Jon Gruden
and well that has meshed and how it
might mesh beyond this year so much
evaluation of him by a lot of fans and
folks in positions like mine about how
their relationship is I love the fact
that Dirk has bought in to what John is
preaching and I think there are a lot of
quarterbacks rich that could look at our
offense right now and say you know I
want to throw the ball more and we've
got a big offensive line we're running
the football we're getting the ball out
quickly in the past game darks getting
protected he's one of the most accurate
quarterbacks in the league when you
protect them and to his credit he's
bought into the whole thing he's become
a leader of this team and he believes in
what John's doing he believes what we're
doing he believes in the run game I give
him a lot of credit he's spreading the
ball around people trying to take Waller
away from us now and you start to see
the emergence of say hunter Renfro so
Dirk has done a great job of buying into
the program and being accurate and you
know last night we had a two-minute
drive to win a football game that's
where your quarterback has to step up
and he did a couple more questions for
you too Mike
you know we go way back and you know how
I approach my job I do want to ask you
about Antonio Brown whose name is in the
news here saying he wants another he
wants another shot he wants to be back
in the league and then he doesn't and he
has been very active on social media
over the last 24 48 hours what what do
you think should happen when Antonio
Brown Mike rich he's not my concern
anymore okay and I will leave it at that
then and now no I hear you
I just felt any of that asked you right
there and the last thing from you here
this coming weekend let's put you back a
little bit in the role that I've enjoyed
being with you for so long with Alabama
playing LSU and one versus two in terms
of quarterbacks potentially coming out
in the draft
two things one how big of a game is this
in terms of NFL prospects for you Mike
as a GM as huge as a matter of fact I
was supposed to be at that game hmm and
I had to cancel my flight just because
we got some things going on here I got
it I got to take care of but it pains me
not to be there tomorrow
on the field pregame watching all these
guys going around from a perspective of
the draft and prospects it's one of the
games every year or every team and every
Scout is gonna look at this game about
30 times and it's good against good ones
against one well you know whatever you
want to talk talk about but you get a
true benchmark of the top players in the
country playing against each other in a
game of magnitude so this game is going
to be scrutinized it's gonna be one of
the most scrutinized games of the year
and then in terms of these two kids at
quarterback do you think when all push
comes to shove on a draft night through
the town evaluation crucible that that
this game could be the difference as to
who gets drafted over the other Mike I
don't know who's declaring for the draft
and who isn't and right point rich I
guess in terms generally a game where
we're going against each other's
defenses in a game where kids who are at
the same position could could this make
a difference when an evaluation is made
push comes to shove when you're on a
clock let's put it that way generally I
think the media focus of two versus Boro
they're never on the field at the same
time obviously I get frustrated with
that I used to get frustrated at in the
media sometimes I think the point though
that you make is a really good one
regarding the quality of the opposition
so if our people if the if tool was to
come out would people want to focus on
him against LSU's defense absolutely how
he performs on a big stage with a ton of
pressure absolutely same thing with Joe
burrow if he comes out with teams want
to focus on him against Alabama say
absol
there are two three four games a year
that are huge for these guys coming out
of power five conferences and it's not
just the quarterback because every
player on that field on Saturday and I
can't wait to watch it at first bowl on
television and then I'm gonna get the
tape out cuz I'm gonna love going
through that day I bet so last one for
you Mike you think you'll go to an L a
Florida State Pro day for Coach Deion
Sanders what do you think apparently
it's out there Mike no Deion taking the
gig at Florida State it's apparently in
the ice out there oh yeah yeah yeah let
me ask you let me ask you let me flip
the tables here yes question sure yeah I
mean you're you and you and Beyond are
tight do you think he would embrace the
grind would he like that a million
percent a million percent a million
percent goal I do believe that were they
were they were they were the hand over
my heart I think he would be absolutely
embracing it and you know the way he is
with his kids was with his youth and his
high school and his his truth he is that
that's that's real so I think he would
and I think I would love to see a
photograph of you and Raiders gear in
him and Florida State gear at a project
I mean my gosh life is amazing right
well the good news the good news is
you've got an upgrade with Daniel
Jeremiah and those guys strong Davis so
you're in good hands in the draft
brother I love you mike Mayock I don't
care who knows hey take care of yourself
Mike okay I appreciate you right back at
you that's GM of the Oakland Raiders
soon to be Vegas Raiders mike Mayock
fresh off a big Thursday night win right
here on the Rich Eisen show for more of
the Rich Eisen show tune - audience
Channel 239 on DirecTV for free on BR
live or download the Rich Eisen show app